please welcome liam Cunningham
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry what's rich
we have so much to talk about and I want
to make sure we cover everything first
of all this is not just a mania in in
the UK or in this country this is
worldwide Liam you said that the cast
had a chance to experience how insane it
is you were at a soccer game in Spain
that's right correct that's up so here
is where you got a sense of just how
truly global this madness is
overwhelmingly global yeah we were in
there Seville filming in Seville in
Spain
and we were invited very kindly invited
along to a wonderful football match of
Barcelona and one of the biggest games
in the world we were in the hospitality
suite which they had repainted and they
took some photographs a little bit of
video before the match started and as
the crowd filled up they said look who's
in the house and they played the music
showed shots of us there and then all of
a sudden we heard they play the title
track the theme song yeah and the
weirdest thing was hearing 80,000 people
singing along at a football match
these guys could do that
as it go Leedom
I have to say you were
you are mostly good but some of you are
awful I just might make that clear
you